jean marie bockel nous a rejoint merci
monsieur vocal d'être avec nous en
direct je sais pas si vous avez pu
suivre cette dernière question la france
faute il y aura t il des conséquences
sur l'otan par rapport à cette crise des
sous marins qui se déroule actuellement
je voulais la led de la crise est là et
est maintenant largement fait y compris
au début de votre émission donc
l'indignation tout ça évidemment on ne
peut que le partage et
notamment sur la méthode mais au fond ce
qui est intéressant c'est la suite de
quoi cet échec est le signe elle est
évidemment le signe que notre statut de
puissance moyenne voulons assumer sa
position de membre permanent
des instances exécutives des nations
unies est extrêmement difficile
cela veut dire que bien sûr l'otan dont
emmanuel macron avait déclaré de manière
peut-être un peu provocatrice que lt
temps
mort cérébrale est effectivement
aujourd'hui en crise extrêmement grave
toute la question c'est
avant de quitter des instances qu'est ce
qu'on fait et ça nous ramène évidemment
à l'europe bien sûr que l'europe de la
défense tels que des gens comme moi puis
bon la rêvait depuis des décennies elle
n'existe pas bon il ya des choses qui se
passent il y a les capacités de se
concerter il yal esquisse d'une tipp le
26 mai il n'y a pas des transeuropéennes
et quand on voit par exemple l'attitude
des britanniques qui étaient
jusqu'à récemment et encore aujourd'hui
le principal allié de la france mènent
depuis qu'ils ont quitté le break 6 par
matière de défense parce que tout
simplement c'est l'autre pays européens
importants qui est capable de s'engager
lorsque ce nécessaire ce qui n'est
actuellement pas le pad le cas
l'allemagne et bien effectivement nous
sommes devant une difficulté majeure
alors on peut dire sur marie bockel
quelles conséquences quelles leçons en
tirer
la leçon à tirer c'est de construire
avec quelques partenaires
à marche forcée parce que la nécessité
fait loi une défense européenne à
géométrie variable ça veut dire avec ce
petit ou grand pays qui sont prêts à
aller plus loin un regardez les pays
baltes riad est important de pays
d'europe centrale
regardez l'italie l'espagne les pays-bas
et des pays qui sont prêts à aller plus
loin ensemble
ce qui nous permettra également d'être
solidaire parlera pour des crises d
compris aux salles elles au sahel
d'ailleurs nous sommes bien seul d'une
part et d'autre part créer en n'étant
pas tout seul un rapport de force au
sein des instances de l'otan le temps
est sûre on peut dire que l'otan doit
disparaître donc on doit claquer la
porte je peux entendre ce point de vue
mais tant qu'il n'y a pas autre chose à
faire dire
créant au simple cette instance qui a un
seul mérite celui d'exister ça peut être
utile de temps en temps un et ça nous
est utile parfois y compris là où nous
sommes en première ligne créons un
rapport de force ne claque pas la porte
on peut menacer de claquer la porte oui
hélas les américains très bien embêté
parce que ils ne peuvent pas être tout
seul mais ne confondons pas vitesse et
précipitation créons ce rapport de force
et montrons que y compris vis-à-vis la
chine vis-à-vis de la russie 1 on est
véritablement dans une capacité de peser
à la hauteur de notre poids économique
démographique et je l'espère un groupe
politique moi je ne vois pas d'autres
pistes sauf le repli national un ou des
alliances au coup par coup ou des
petites revanches 1 mais on a pensé bien
qu'on a besoin les uns des autres sa
mère après loin voilà pour moi
[Musique]
la conduite à tenir 2 c'est que le
plaisir matheron est un européen mais ça
ne suffit pas il faut parfois nous
sommes parfois nous français nous sommes
trop arrogant même si nous sommes le
seul pays aujourd'hui européen un qui
accepte de s'engager y compris
militairement dans des crises et ne
suffit pas de dire qu'on a raison tout
seul qu'on peut le bullois club les
autres il faut arriver à convaincre les
autres a évolué et même l'allemagne un
jour elle m'est
le hyaric sur cette opportunité dont
vous parlez de relance est peut-être une
europe de la défense à géométrie
variable
on n'entend pas beaucoup les les
européens réagir à cette crise des sous
marins est ce que c'est pas une affaire
français selon vous patrick le hyaric et
est-ce que c'est l'occasion de relancer
l'europe de la défense
c'est considéré comme une affaire
française ce n'est pas considéré que
dans les autres capitales européennes
comme une affaire européenne et il ya
très peu de solidarité des autres
gouvernement vis-à-vis de notre pays
mais pour revenir à la question de la
défense européenne oui on pourrait
imaginer une défense européenne voire
comme le dit monsieur le ministre
une europe de dents de la défense dans
le cadre d'une coopération décentralisée
c'est-à-dire à géométrie variable parce
que il est bien évident que les pays
d'europe orientale ne seront pas avec
nous sur ce sur une affaire comme celle
là puisque il s'allierait forcément
hauts dirigeants nord américains
mais la question c'est que tant les
traités européens un dernier traité
comme dans celui de maastricht la
question de la défense européenne n'est
abordée que sous l'angle de pilier
européen de l'otan'' étape vers van der
leyen la semaine dernière dans son
discours de l'union comme on dit elle a
répété cette phrase puisqu'elle a dit à
propos de ce jeu vous propose de
l'écouter et vous
de l'europe proviennent de la défense
elle dit qui devrait aller de pair avec
le renforcement du pilier européen de
l'otan autrement dit il n'ya pas de
souveraineté européenne la dent
malheureusement on les coups sûrs c'est
l'avant ne relaye année et on en parle
plus
nous avons besoin d'une évaluation
commune des menaces auxquelles nous
sommes confrontés et d'une approche
commune pour y faire face c'est pourquoi
nous organiserons avec emmanuel macron
pendant la présidence française du
conseil de l'union européenne un sommet
de la défense européenne à toulouse jean
marie bockel pour qu'il y ait un accord
sur une défense européenne il faut que
politiquement tout le monde soit
d'accord et que les menaces soient les
mêmes a priori
les affaires de défense vendent
aujourd'hui pour les puissances moyennes
l'une c'est forcément une souveraineté
partagée il ya des démences souveraineté
comporte à ce pâle comme la cyber
défense comme en l'occurrence la
dissuasion nucléaire mais tout le reste
c'est à dire les enjeux concrets d'une
politique de défense d'une capacité
d'intervention et cetera c'est une
souveraineté partagée donc l'idée 1
c'est avec des européens qui seraient
prêts à s'engager
madame von der leyen a raison de faire
cette composition tout présence
française mais je crains que on à 27 on
n'avait pas très loin parce que certains
pays sont très réticents un non pas
comme l'allemagne la même doctrine
d'emploi ou ce sens qu'ils sont pas
prêts à intervenir de manière active
comme c'est nécessaire et c'est la
raison pour laquelle un certain nombre
de pays européens
effectivement doivent aller plus loin et
doivent constituer au sein de l'otan
puisque le temps existe et que vous
voyez aujourd'hui
par exemple au sahel 1 même si nous
sommes en froid avec les américains et
pour une bonne raison 1 mais au niveau
de la surveillance spatiale d'eads road
de la logistique un dd
de la consommation de carburant etc nous
avons besoin de ses alliés ce sont deux
alliés jusqu'à preuve du contraire et
donc on peut être contre position tout à
fait respectable mais mon opinion c'est
qu'on n'a pas d'avion zipper
l'alliance alternative seul qu'on n'y
arrivera pas donc je ne vois qu'une voie
et que l'europe est davantage au sein
des instances de l'otan et sachez que
les américains eux mêmes sont en crise
ils sont de plus en plus tourné on l'a
bien vu d'ailleurs avec l'australie vers
les enjeux pacifique donc la question
d'être le principal contributeur de
l'otan au fond c'est aussi un problème
pour eux un pour connaître d'ailleurs
que l'otan c'est aussi un moyen pour les
américains d'imposer leurs produits
leurs industries de l'armement donc là
on est très clairement dans le rapport
de forces est et ne l'avons pas le
rapport de force nous on se retire pour
la pointe des pieds on peut le faire on
peut voir même une position pacifiste
incertain selon un dans dans l'opinion
française des six responsables français
où on est plus forts ensemble voilà il
faut bien commencer avec ceux qui sont
prêts à y aller sinon on tournera en
rond pendant des décennies voilà ma
position patrick le hyaric une réaction
oui mais je comprends bien
l'orientation de monsieur le ministre ce
jeune c'est une position que défend mais
je ne suis pas d'accord parce que
l'automne c'est-à-dire cette alliance
militaire c'est pourquoi pour qui et
contre qui si c'est une stratégie
belliciste vis-à-vis de la chine
essentiellement et de la russie de temps
en temps je pense que c'est une mauvaise
stratégie
il vaudrait mieux discuter d'une d'une
stratégie générale qui pousse à la
coopération et la paix là le surarmement
généralisé auquel on est en train
d'assister de part et d'autre est très
inquiétant pour l'avenir ne croyons pas
que il ne puisse pas y avoir un jour un
accident par conséquent
l'otan'' aujourd'hui est devenue une
groupe a en quelque cent essentiellement
sous commandement américain et
nous-mêmes l'union euros elle est
considérée par les par les états unis
comme un supplétif pour leur propre
stratégie d'ailleurs donné on peut
peut-être faire un sommet de la défense
à toulouse si c'est pour défendre notre
industrie de la défense est symbolique
de le faire là mais il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui qu'il y a beaucoup de
matériel militaire qui se fend et même
la conception du matériel humaine dépend
de l'autorisation des états unis en
matière de drones en matière de même en
matière de cybersécurité vous dites que
ça se partage pas oui vous avez raison
mais en matière de cybersécurité
c'est quand même les américains qui
aujourd'hui dispose de l'ensemble de
l'arsenal numérique la ministre allemand
de la défense a déclaré que la débâcle
afghane démontrait je cite la nécessité
d'une force de réaction rapide
européenne écoutez
c'est à dire que vous aviez bien mais
les oyats vers notre situation ça vous
avez senti faire faire des gains de
temps nous devons mieux ne pas réagir
dans la suite
la ministre de la défense qui finalement
fait un pas de plus vers l'idée de cette
europe de la défense jean marie bockel
alors qu'elle s'était montré
farouchement opposés on s'en souvient il
ya quelques temps est ce qu'il est une
progression dans les esprits avec
notamment le le conflit et la prise du
pouvoir des talibans en afghanistan
était je l'espère en tout cas ce que
nous les frais peuvent en dire c'est que
nous sommes d'accord sur
les risques les risques de comporte une
verrine de l'otan qui ne serait que la
chose de lui pas une et avec des
européens comme supplétifs de reprendre
votre expression
j'ai moi même siéger pendant cinq ans
avant de quitter le sénat à l'assemblée
parlementaire de l'otan où nous sommes
très actifs comme européen mais où n'a
pas ce sentiment donc pour moi c'est
clair que l'otan aux portes ces risques
le temps doit donc évoluer on ne peut
pas être associé stratégique qu'il soit
agressif comme vous l'avez dit c'est un
point de vue que je partage par contre
la différence que nous avons c'est que
j'aurai attacher une alliance aveux doit
d'évoluer et donc la question que vous
posez un instant un sur les y at-il
aujourd'hui avec la nouvelle donne
géopolitique
un d investiture de l'afghanistan mais
on pourrait revenir sur le sel une
capacité de renforcer
d'une certaine solidarité plus une
solidarité l'organisation européenne et
ça vaut aussi pour les autres
d'armements par un par rapport à gré au
complexe militaro industriel américain
d'irak est une réalité les perspectives
que nous nous donnons d'avion de blindés
mais souvent à long terme sont de bonnes
choses mais il faut à un moment donné
surtout s'adapter la cuisse
géopolitiques et militaires ça tapait
capacité même de les projeter ensemble
l'aspect bien sûr armement rencontrer le
rapport de force sinon l'europe
politique n'existera jamais et dans le
monde de plus en plus jour ne rangera
dans lequel nous sommes nous risquons
d'avoir notamment vis-à-vis de nos
alliés américains qui montrent rien
l'heure est au centre et si on en voit
partout nombre de situations de cruelles
des contenus et la lah l'amitié avec les
états unis comme d'ailleurs avec les
britanniques d'autres ne sera que
renforcée par un meilleur rapport de
force et c'est vrai que la france un qui
n'a pas abandonné son petit pet ans
contrairement à d'autres pays et qui
même renforcé même si nous restons une
puissance moyenne peut jouer un rôle
important les conditions n'ont pas
simplement de se plaindre ne pas
simplement des relations 1 mais d'avoir
des alliés sûrs aux sables de l'union
européenne c'est pas gagné d'avancé
merci beaucoup jean marie bockel et
merci à vous patrick le hyaric d'avoir
participé à ce débat en direct sur arte
france dans la matinale